Es ist eine absolute sensation in der jobs pyramide wurde eine neue riesige geheime kammer entdeckt und das mit
teilchenphysik aber welche geheimnisse verbirgt
Und wie kann sie jetzt erreicht werden jetzt endlich zum tricksen wie ist die lage der geheimkammer in der jobs pyramide
herzlich willkommen
Die ägyptologie ist eine der absolut spannendsten wissenschaften immer wieder werden neue geheimnisse und tausende jahre alte artefakte
entdeckt erst vor kurzem zwei riesige statuen ägyptische pharaonen und noch
So einiges dürfte unter dem wüstensand in ägypten verborgen sein oder sogar?
Direkt vor unseren augen in den pyramiden immer wieder wird dort gesucht mit immer
Moderneren methoden erst vor einigen jahren wurde mit einem roboter ein seltsamer gang entdeckte aber im nichts
Endete und jetzt jetzt haben
teilchenphysiker ein neues wirklich großes geheimnis in der cheops-pyramide
Entdeckt und das ist wirklich riesig eine 30 meter lange und acht meter
Hohe kamera oberhalb der galerie des ganges der zur königs kammer führt aber wie konnte die kammer
Jahrtausende verborgen bleiben und wie konnte sie jetzt entdeckt werden die
Teilchenphysik macht es möglich erst mal ist das verfahren simpel war aber bisher in dieser
größenordnung einfach nicht möglich röntgen das durchleuchten von materien mit strahlen die durch sie durchdringen für uns menschen geht das ganz einfach mit einem röntgengerät
Doch eines zu bauen das so groß ist um eine pyramide zu durchleuchten
Dass es schlicht und einfach unmöglich deshalb kamen die archäologen auf die findige idee sich mit
Teilchenphysiker zusammenzutun vielleicht gibt es ja teilchen die durch die materie dringen und sowieso durch den raum fliegen und genauso war es
Millionen sind die lösung sie entstehen wenn protonen aus dem weltall auf unsere atmosphäre treffen dabei zerfallen
atomkerne und es entstehen diese millionen sie sind wie elektronen negativ geladenen zerfallen aber bereits nach 22 millisekunden
Also war sie schnell vom aus und betrachtet existieren sie aber gott sei dank viel länger die
relativitätstheorie macht es möglich sie bewegen sich fast mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
Fort deshalb wirkt die zeit der nation auf sie sie haben für uns rund zehn
mal mehr zeit bis sie zerfallen dieser zeit können sie die erdoberfläche
Erreichen und auf dem weg durch materie werden sie dann abgelenkt fliegen sie nicht durch materie werden sie nicht abgelenkt stellt man in einer pyramide
also unterhalb eines hohlraums
Detektoren auf treffen dort mehr mehr millionen auf als unter einer dicken stein schicht wie mit einem röntgengerät können jetzt auf diese weise
Hohlräume entdeckt werden und genau das ist jetzt passiert oberhalb der galerie muss es nach den messungen der
Teilchenphysiker einen riesigen raum geben 30 meter lang und acht meter hoch aber was hat es mit diesem. Hohlraum
Aufsicht die spekulationen schießen jetzt ins kraut von da gibt es keinen hohlraum über das ist ein entlastung
Der wie in der königs kammer den druck der steinmassen auf die galerie darunter ableiten sollen bis zu das ist die eigentliche grabkammer
gibt da sein meister
Im verstecken noch ist alles ziemlich unklar sollte es eine strenge kammer sein so glauben angelogen und
archäologen sei sie auf keinen fall eine chance oder grabkammer weil ja alles nach unten rutschen würde die haben aber offensichtlich noch nichts von
stufen gehört man stelle sich nur mal einen schrägen nach oben ansteigen den riesigen raum voller schätze vor ein
Riesiger berg würde sich da vor allem auf turm
Wahnsinn was für eine perspektive die kann man könnte aber auch einfach nur vage recht sein da werden diese
Gegenargumente sowieso makulatur aber wie kann man das jetzt herausfinden ist es nur ein riesiger staubiger raum oder eine schatzkammer voller gold
Noch hat niemand eine idee denn es scheint keine zugänge zu dem raum zu geben und ob je eine bohrung dazu
zu diesem raum erlaubt wird das ist äußerst fraglich wenn es neuigkeiten gibt dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier wenn ihr kein video dazu und
Auch, zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann jagt ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann verpasst er kann wie ihr das mit der zeit die nation erklärt übrigens hier in die relativitätstheorie
Einfach erklärt danach habt ihr hoffentlich keine fragen mehr und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran